on the Republicans assault on immigrants
and immigration and I'm sure we'll have
many more parts to come I worry that
today will be more of the same with my
Republican colleagues once again showing
us that they are not serious about
governing and finding solutions to the
complex issue of immigration
after passing their extreme cruel and
unworkable Border Bill where the only
bipartisan thing about it was the
opposition Republicans have spent the
last few weeks fear-mongering over the
end of title 42. this fear-mongering
about the Border let me be clear
empowers the Smugglers and cartels when
our Republican colleagues claim that the
border is open that is the most
important information that they use to
continue their activities turns into
disinformation and misinformation shared
by Smugglers distributed by social media
and stoked by Relentless right-wing
media lies and shouts of open borders
all of which fuel migration patterns and
yet what are the facts the facts are
that when title 42 a public health
policy not an immigration enforcement
policy finally ended what happened
border encounters plummeted by 70
percent thus far the increased migration
narrative pushed in the right-wing media
has not yet come the lower numbers are
likely due at least in part to the Biden
administration's new policies announced
in the lead-up to the end of title 42.
these announcements detailed how they
plan to address migration to the
Southwest border going forward the
administration showed that once again
Democrats have real workable solutions
to manage migration and expand legal
pathways on top of the parole programs
created by the Biden Administration
earlier this year the administration
announced the creation of additional
legal Pathways that are intended to
relieve pressure at the border the
administration announced that their
opening Regional processing centers
Across the Western Hemisphere for for
the first time to facilitate access to
Legal Pathways in the United States this
is an important step to allow migrants
to get their protection and benefits
claims assessed in a humane way without
having to make the dangerous Journey to
the U.S Mexico border the administration
is also creating new family
reunification parole processes for El
Salvador Guatemala Honduras and Colombia
this is for people who already have an
approved family petition modeled off of
the Cuban family reunification program
my colleagues attempted to codify an hr2
the administration is also increasing
the number of appointments that will be
available under the CBP one app which
while far from perfect does increase CBC
cbp's ability to process more migrants
the administration also implemented new
policies that I do have significant
concerns about this includes a new
Asylum regulation that limits us access
to Asylum for those who cross between
ports of Entry as well as new expedited
processing of single adults from
Spanish-speaking countries where
individuals will get an initial Asylum
screaming in a border patrol facility
now none of these Solutions are perfect
addressing the issue of migration is
difficult but Democrats have shown time
and time again that we take this complex
humanitarian crisis seriously by
creating a more Humane immigration
system that recognizes the horrific
conditions that cause migrants to flee
as well as contributions of immigrants
to America we can decrease unauthorized
Crossings strengthen our economy and
protect migrants and citizens from harm
unfortunately Republicans have showed us
their priorities with their border Bill
and now with their fiscal year 2024
Department of Homeland Security
Appropriations bill that bill would only
create more disorder at the border
budgets are moral documents that show
what we value and prioritize their bill
which was released last week defunds the
emergency food and shelter program which
is helping migrants who are processed by
CBP move away from the border to be with
sponsors or family in the United States
as they await their court hearing their
bill ends the use of family case
management program which had a nearly
100 percent success rate in helping
families show up for their Immigration
Court hearings and it disallows the use
of alternatives to detention unless the
secretary himself directly approves it
which would create a significant
bottleneck for moving people out of CBP
custody it defunds the Asylum officer
rule which allows Asylum officers to
adjudicate Asylum claims helps allevia
the growing Immigration Court backlog
and it ends the use of the cbp-1 app for
people who are coming in through parole
which will severely hamper cbp's ability
to process migrants in a safe and
orderly way now all of these policy
choices give the game away none of these
policy choices are intended to help the
agency they will create more chaos and
disorder at the border but that appears
to be the point of my Republican
colleagues efforts create chaos and
disorder and hope hope to win the next
election now if the chairman of the
subcommittee is so concerned about
airplanes being grounded I would just
say that the default on America Act and
the attempts that Republicans are making
right now to put forward serious cuts
that default would actually halt all of
the air traffic controllers across the
country I look forward to hearing from
all of our Witnesses today the American
people deserve better and I hope that
our witnesses can shed light on real
solutions to address the situation at
our border in a holistic way and with
that I yield back Mr chairman thank you
the chair now recognizes the chairman of
the house Judiciary Committee Mr Jordan
I think the chairman the ranking member
started her statement by saying the
border is secure
really
more than 5.5 more than five and a half
million illegal aliens along the
Southwest border have been encountered
since Joe Biden took office two million
of these illegal aliens have been
released in the American communities and
more than one and a half million known
illegal gotaways have successfully
crossed the Southwest border undetected
these include criminal gang members drug
dealers and individuals on the terrorist
watch list that is not a secure border
that is not a closed border I never said
that I never started my statement that
is secure border that has happened
I'm correcting the record because you
stated something that was not true thank
you General ladies should know that
interrupting a member without making a
valid point of order is is against the
the rules of the committee
the time belongs to the chairman
Chairman's recognized I would just point
out the gentlelady said Republicans say
the border is open she said that's not
so is that so what what does that mean
if it's not open and so is it something
that's not secure not close I would just
I would just saying what she referenced
in her opening statement day one of this
Administration they stopped construction
of the wall they ended remain in Mexico
and they put back in place catch and
release day one that is why we have the
situation we do
in that same time period I just talked
about
28 months of this Administration over 43
000 pounds of fentanyl have been seized
at the Southwest border with an unknown
amount making it into our communities
and there's also been an uptick in the
number of individuals in the FBI
terrorist watch list
just two weeks ago border patrol
apprehended an Afghan uh who illegally
crossed into San Diego sector in
California and Days Later news reports
indicate that an additional five watch
listed illegal aliens were apprehended
in Tucson Arizona after attempting to
avoid detection
our Witnesses today understand the
consequences of our borders being
unprotected all too well all of them and
I want to thank them for being here
today
I want to particularly thank Miss Nobles
for bravely agreeing to appear here
today
to talk about the unthinkable tragedy
that affected her family her daughter
Kaylee was 20 years old when she was
assaulted and murdered the person
charged with the crime was an MS-13 gang
member who was allowed to enter the
United States after crossing the border
illegally as a so-called unaccompanied
alien child
despite the USC having a criminal
history in El Salvador for MS-13 gang
affiliation well before he even entered
the United States law enforcement only
became aware of this fact after
Kaylee's murder
why not until after Kaylee's murder
because prior to the murder no one in
this Administration bothered to check
into the uac's criminal history in his
home country and the Hamilton family was
not alone this year in experiencing such
a horrific event in January
suspected cartel members massacred six
people including a 10-month-old infant
assassination style in Goshen California
in April of this year a nationwide
manhood Manhunt ensued after a man who
was who had been deported on four
separate occasions
killed five people including a
nine-year-old boy
it's well past time that we enforce the
law secure our border and we should pass
the Senate should pass the bill that we
pass in the house just a few weeks ago
so we can get our border under control
and secure with that Mr chairman I yield
back
chair now recognizes the ranking member
of the House Judiciary Committee Mr
Nadler
thank you Mr chairman
I first wish to express my most sincere
condolences to miss miss Noble Nobles
I'm so sorry for your loss and I thank
you for coming to tell us uh Kayla's
story May her memory be a blessing
Mr chairman the United States has a long
history of welcoming Asylum Seekers to
our Shores my constituents in Manhattan
are able to see a reminder of this
history every day in the Statue of
Liberty welcoming the tired the poor and
huddled the masses yearning to breathe
free
throughout our history refugees from
near and far have sought safety here and
while our laws have never been perfect
they have always allowed at least some
refugees to enter
a modern Refugee program and the world's
view about our Collective responsibility
for refugees were radically reshaped by
the Holocaust when the United States
joined both Canada and Cuba and turning
away the MS St Louis under more than 900
Jewish passengers in 1939 we allowed
Asylum Seekers to be returned to
persecution in Europe nearly one-third
of the boat's passengers perished at the
hands of the Nazis
many other countries also turned away
Jewish refugees during World War II The
Hires that followed led to the creation
of the United Nations and ultimately to
the international Refugee framework that
we still use today
took a while for domestic laws to catch
up to our International commitments so
when Congress moved too slowly
presidents use their expansive
immigration powers to help get people to
safety
in 1956 President Eisenhower oversaw the
parole of over 30 000 Hungarian refugees
into the United States
more Parolees followed including more
than 58 000 Cubans between 1961 and
1962.
15 000 Chinese refugees from Hong Kong
between 1962 and 1966 and over a hundred
and thirty thousand Southeast Asian
refugees following the fall of Saigon in
1975.
we passed the refugee Act of 1980 with
overwhelming bipartisan support which
established the domestic framework for
Refugee and decidedly processing the
commitment by residents by presidents
and lawmakers of both parties to accept
refugees solidifies solidified our
country status as a symbol of Hope for
those trying to escape persecution
sadly that came to a crashing halt under
the Trump Administration
former president Trump slashed our
Refugee program both at home and abroad
implemented discriminatory bands
demonized immigrants separated families
and put all of this focus into building
a wall between ourselves and Mexico
but still people came because the
dangers they face on their Journeys here
paled in comparison to the Harvest from
which they were fleeing
covet exacerbated the problems and
president Trump used authorities under
title 42 a policy to protect Public
Health to turn away Asylum Seekers
arriving at the Borden
when President Biden came into office he
reversed course on many of the prior
administrations most heinous policies
but title 42 remained even while our
Republican colleagues claimed that the
Border was open and that President Biden
and secretary mayorkas were purposefully
inviting an invasion in quotes of
migrants to our Shores these claims were
used by Smugglers to entice migrants to
make the journey North and echoed by
mass Shooters in their manifestos
the Biden Administration has been
working to get our immigration system
back on track but Republicans have been
fighting him every step of the way
they voted to end the covid emergency
declaration but they said that the
administration should not end its use of
title 42 even though that policy was
tied to the pandemic
they passed the messaging bill over
bipartisan opposition that would
decimate our Asylum system and send
vulnerable people back into Harm's Way
in the weeks leading up to title 42's
expiration they Stoke fears that we
would see chaos and massive numbers of
migrants crossing at the border and yet
what happened
thanks to the policies put in place by
the by the administration the numbers of
the Border dropped by dropped by 70
percent following the expiration of
title 42 but the fear-mongering
continues
unfortunately my colleagues are not ones
to let facts get in the way of a good
story
latest example comes from my home state
of New York where Orange County
Republicans claimed that homeless
veterans were being displaced by
migrants
this was quickly echoed by the speaker
of the house and other Congressional
Republicans and even by one of our
Witnesses
on the screen a tweet after tweet by my
Republican colleagues amplifying the
story to stoke fears about the border
and to distract from their own failures
to enact meaningful Solutions
yet he yet the claims contained in the
story have turned out to be completely
unfounded
with even the New York Post running a
retraction
so here we are again in another hearing
about the quote Biden border crisis
close quote I'm sure that no matter what
happens to the Border we will continue
to have hearings on this topic
and we will continue to see partisan
messaging bills that have no chance of
ever becoming law
as one of my Republican colleagues said
there's a reason why we haven't gotten
significant border security done and why
we haven't seen significant immigration
reform done it is in the interests of
many politicians to have this crisis
continue to flare up
Democrats are willing to work with
serious Republicans to make changes to
our immigration system that would allow
people to come here lawfully while
ensuring the Safety and Security of our
citizens we want it to have the tough
conversations about the best path
forward and we have passed bipartisan
legislation that has addressed some of
the thorniest issues like the farm
Workforce modernization Act
but so long as this majority insists on
its partisan blame games we are just
going to keep talking past each other
and nothing will be solved I look
forward to hearing from our Witnesses
today thank you for coming to speak
about your experience and your expertise
and I yield back the balance of my time
without objection all other opening
statements will be included in the
record I'll now introduce the four
Witnesses we have today uh the first
will be the honorable Rodney Scott Chief
Scott served over 29 years in the United
States border patrol before retiring as
chief of the border patrol in August of
2021 during that time he held numerous
leadership positions at various stations
and sectors along the Southwest border
as well as several leadership and
specialized assignments at U.S Customs
and Border Protection headquarters our
second witness will be Mr Mark Hetfield
Mr headfield has been the president and
CEO of the Hebrew immigration Aid
Society since 2013. prior to that he
held several other positions at the
society worked as an immigration
attorney and worked for the Immigration
and Naturalization Service the Hebrew
immigration Aid societies and
non-governmental organization that
settles refugees and provides illegal
services to aliens I will now yield to
the gentleman from new New York Mr
Lawler to introduce the third Witness
thank you Mr chairman it is my distinct
pleasure to introduce Our Town orange
Town supervisor Teresa Kenny a lifelong
Rockland County resident who cares
deeply for her residence and their
quality of life
supervisor Kenny is a attorney and
daughter of a retired New York City
police officer she has both a deep
appreciation for the rule of law and a
deep knowledge of our legal system prior
to serving as supervisor she served as
Deputy Town attorney for the town of
orange town and practice real estate law
and private practice for over 30 years I
can think of no one better to highlight
the gross overreach by mayor Eric Adams
and other officials in New York
attempting to usurp local zoning laws
then Teresa Kenny and he claimed that
our border is secure
you need not look further than New York
where New York City has taken in over 65
000 migrants since this crisis
exacerbated last year the governor and
the mayor are asking for an emergency
declaration they have nowhere else to
house these migrants so the idea that we
do not have open borders is laughable on
its face couple that with New York
Sanctuary City policy and you have a
recipe for disaster in New York City and
it is spilling out into communities all
across New York State and that is why
Teresa Kenny's testimony here today is
invaluable to this committee
thank you and then we will finally hear
from Ms Tammy Nobles Ms Nobles is a
realtor from Norfolk Virginia she
volunteers part-time as the president of
the Down Syndrome Association of Hampton
Roads and she is the mother of Kayla
Hamilton
we welcome our our Witnesses we thank
them for appearing today and we'll Begin
by swearing you in would you please rise
and raise your right hand
do you swear or a firm under penalty of
perjury that the testimony you were
about to give is true and correct to the
best of your knowledge information and
belief so help you God
let the record reflect that the
witnesses have answered in the
affirmative thank you and be receded
please know that your written testimony
will be entered in the record in its
entirety accordingly we we'd ask that
you summarize your testimony in five
minutes and we'll begin with Chief
Rodney Scott
you want to turn turn your mic on
oh sorry it was reflectors on I
apologize General McClintock Reiki
member Jai Paul
chairman Jordan ranking member Nadler
thank and members of the committee thank
you for having me here today
I am currently a senior distinguished
fellow for border security immigration
at the Texas public policy Foundation
but as stated before joining Texas
public policy I served 29 years as
United States border patrol agent
I started out as a GS5 border patrol
agent trainee and was competitively
competitively promoted through the Civil
Service ranks it was ultimately promoted
to Chief I served as President Biden's
chief of U.S border Patrol until I
retired in August 2021 I think it's
important to know I was never a
political appointee
over my career I was honored to
participate in the transformation of an
uncontrolled chaotic Southwest border to
a border that was increasingly secure
meaningful progress started in 1994
under the Clinton Administration when a
strategy proposed by U.S border Patrol
was adopted
that strategy used focused Personnel
deployments barriers technology and
consequences for violations of law to
reduce the chaos of illegal immigration
and free up agents to focus on Public
Safety threats
the basic principles of this successful
strategy endured every presidential
Administration until January 2021.
my first hand experience has taught me
that border security and immigration are
two distinctly different yet
interrelated issues border security is
simply knowing and controlling who and
what is entering our homeland
Immigration and Customs laws are
completely irrelevant if you cannot
control the initial entry
the terrorist attacks on 9 11 also had a
profound impact on my understanding of
border security
prior to 9 11 terrorism was not part of
the Border Patrol's discussions but this
changed as our nation realized that
foreign terrorists had exploited
vulnerabilities in our border security
Congress responded quickly by creating
the Department of Homeland Security and
I responded by accepting an opportunity
to build the office of anti-terrorism
within Customs and Border Protection I
quickly found myself immersed in
classified intelligence briefings and
interagency planning to mitigate
terrorist threats
the terrorists that perpetrated 911
entered through our ports of entry and
as such our priority was improving the
ports of Entry but we knew that as we
mitigated those vulnerabilities
terrorists would predictively shift to
entering in between the ports of Entry
we also had reason to believe that the
terrorist organizations would
increasingly seek operatives that were
unknown to U.S intelligence
so we could not rely solely on records
checks we would need skilled
interviewers
the border patrol strategy evolved with
an increased focus on situational
awareness through intelligence and
physical surveillance
however deterring illegal immigration
through a certainty of arrest and
application of consequences remained a
fundamental fundamental pillar
when I was selected as Chief the
capabilities of the border patrol to
detect and interdict illegal entries was
better than ever and it was rapidly
improving
fewer illegal entries combined with the
construction of the new border wall
system made every agent more effective
this equated to additional time that
agents were spending on interviews to
identify somebody positively and as well
as their intent and to glean
Intelligence on criminal networks that
was used to improve investigations and
operations
in contrast I also experienced the
reversal of border security and
immigration policy that was initiated by
the by Administration
from day one political leadership
ignored career professionals and
increasingly made policy decisions that
resulted in thousands of aliens being
released into the United States
as predicted the volume of illegal
immigration rapidly increased it
overwhelmed border patrol and
effectively transferred control of the
United States border with Mexico to the
drug cartels
I watch border security gains that have
been made over three decades vanish and
the safety of Border communities spiral
backwards
policymakers must understand this is not
simply an immigration issue this is a
national security threat cartels use
illegal aliens to overwhelm law
enforcement create controllable gaps in
border security that then they exploit
to bring in anything they want
to thank the well-resourced terrorist
networks and hostile nations are not
exploiting the same vulnerability as
naive
prioritizing immigration processing over
enforcement also means that the agents
are spread so thin when they are
deployed that even when they detect an
illegal entry they are not always able
to interdict it these events are
reported by the border patrol as known
godaways but it's also important to know
that this does not Encompass the total
godaways the hundreds of miles of border
that are being that are left unpatrolled
on a daily or weekly basis now and that
lack persistent surveillance we have no
idea what it's crossed to those areas
in my professional assessment the U.S
border Patrol has lost our ability to
know who and what is entering our
homeland and please remember the border
is simply a Transit location is not a
destination
people and these things are going to
every city town and state across this
nation I look forward to your questions
thank you next we'll hear from Mr Mark
Hatfield
Mr chairman ranking member Jeff Hall and
members of the subcommittee I thank you
for this opportunity to join you today
to speak about securing our border
highest founded over 120 years ago as
the Hebrew immigrants Aid Society is the
oldest Refugee organization in the world
we were founded to help refugees because
they were Jewish today we help refugees
because we are Jewish we resettle
refugees across the United States in
partnership with the United States
government and Jewish communities we
also operate in 22 other countries half
of which are in Latin America working to
help refugees find welcome and safety in
their countries of asylum
is old enough to remember the importance
of American leadership in drafting the
refugee Convention of 1951 and the
refugee Act of 1980 which passed this
chamber and was signed into law with
strong bipartisan support
these Landmark measures were intended to
ensure that never again would people
fleeing persecution be turned back to
their persecutors
today however our Asylum and immigration
and Border Protection Systems are in
dire need of investment updating and
repair we can all agree that the status
quo is absolutely unacceptable
Congress has not addressed legal
immigration Pathways in over three
decades the pretext for not doing so is
that we cannot fix legal immigration
Pathways until we fix the Border this is
a false Choice ignoring the laws of
supply and demand
we cannot fix the Border without also
reforming legal immigration pathways
as long as there are jobs to fill that
American citizens cannot or will not do
the US government will not be able to
secure the Border Congress needs to
establish more pathways
as long as the government continues to
invest in Immigration Enforcement
Officers without investing in
Immigration judges and Asylum officers
and in a more fair and efficient Asylum
system we will not be able to secure the
Border otherwise people will continue to
apply for Asylum and be assigned a court
date many years into the future
as long as the system continues to leave
people in limbo for decades like TPS
recipients streamers humanitarian
Parolees and people who have withholding
of removal with no Pathway to permanent
residence or family reunion you will not
be able to secure the Border
so long as it's difficult for Asylum
Seekers to access legal counsel you
won't be able to secure the Border
because they will not have access to
advice on whether or not they qualify
and should proceed with their
application
highest welcomes of Biden
administration's announcement that it is
establishing resettlement processing
centers in South and Central America in
order to secure the Border we need such
safe and legal Pathways for fleeing for
their lives to access resettlement but
as a safer complement to Asylum not as a
substitute
similarly we welcome the Biden
administration's earlier decision to
reopen the Central American miners
program so children will no longer have
to risk their lives to reunite with
family across the border
separating families pushing people back
without a hearing for their Asylum
claims and subjecting Asylum Seekers to
inhumane conditions on both sides of the
Border in detention shames us but will
not deter people from coming here as
they have no better options
my written testimony details the story
of one highest client in Mexico from
Venezuela who after struggling with the
Glitchy cbp1 app was locked in Mexican
immigration detention in March in Juarez
when the fire broke out where detainees
were locked in their cells and could not
Escape 40 people were killed but he
survived by keeping his head in the
toilet throughout the ordeal he's now in
the United States receiving medical
treatment for the burns all over his
body
my written statement provides details on
his proposed approaches to the many
challenges at the border I cannot over
emphasize however that there are no easy
or cheap solutions to make up for
decades of underinvestment neglect and
polarization around this issue we hope
we can rely on the administration and
Congress in this subcommittee to find
bipartisan solutions that provide the
legal Pathways and the enforcement
mechanisms necessary to restore
equilibrium and integrity to our Asylum
and immigration systems
in the meantime there need to be
additional resources at the border and
within our Asylum system but those
resources cannot be solely focused on
apprehension removal and detention or on
removal without a screening the
administration should not replace one
legal fiction barring Asylum Seekers on
health grounds with another barring them
because they did not go through Asylum
systems that are even more dysfunctional
than our own
in the immediate term the administration
in Congress should focus on increasing
resources for the fair and efficient
adjudication of Asylum claims on
elastian and first out basis with legal
counseling and measures to ensure that
CBP follows a law and their own
procedures to ensure that no one is sent
back into Harm's Way
the refugee admissions program should be
resourced to be safe and orderly for
Pathways so that people can rely on U.S
law rather than on Smugglers
we are not the only country facing this
humanitarian Challenge and we cannot
solve it alone thank you
thank you we're next here from Super
provisor Theresa Kinney thank you thank
you Mr chairman and every member of the
subcommittee for giving me the
opportunity to speak with you today
about what transpired with mayor Eric
Adams and his efforts to house migrants
in a local hotel in Orange Town New York
I'm here today as the town supervisor of
orange town a suburban community
approximately 30 miles north of New York
City to give you some insight into what
is happening around the country as a
result of the migration crisis at the
southern border it is important to note
at the onset that what is happening in
Orange town is not unique it is playing
out throughout communities all over our
country as major cities are reaching
capacity for migrant housing and they
are sending them to other communities
without any regard for whether they have
the resources or capabilities to handle
them
orange Town's story began on Friday May
5th when New York city mayor Adams
called to tell me about a pilot program
he was implementing as part of his
decompression strategy the plan he
explained was to relocate migrants from
New York City and to house them in
hotels all across New York State his
call is to let me know that a hotel in
Orange Town had been identified as a
possible location mayor Adams downplayed
the plan telling me there was a chance
that no one would be housed in Orange
County and he applied it would be
happening in weeks when pressed for
specifics he told me that a member of
his team would get back to me I received
a call from a member of the mayor's
staff and that's what I learned that the
plan was to house single adult males in
a local hotel and that the buses would
be arriving imminently in fact it was in
within hours of that call that I
received photos of hundreds of
mattresses stacked outside the Armani
Inn and Suites hotel and it was evident
to me that the plan had been in the
works for quite some time
and that it included giving local
elected officials very little advance
notice as a means to thwart legal
challenges throughout the following days
it became clear that the New York City
intended to house 340 men at the Armani
Inn and Suites a local a hotel in
Orangeburg a small Hamlet of just over
three square miles and a population of
approximately 4 500 people the hotel is
situated less than a mile from two
college campuses two senior citizenly
housing complexes and a high school
is located at the intersection of New
York State Route 303 which is one of the
most dangerous highways in the county
and Kings Highway a street of mostly
residential homes
made around his plan was simple to
convert the hotel in Orange Town into a
housing facility for long-term residents
or in other words to open a New York
City homeless shelter in Orange town
which is a clear violation of our local
zoning standards So based upon this
information and what was garnered from
the phone calls and the observations of
medical supplies and other shelter items
by Town officials who inspected the
property the town issued a notice of
violation to advise the hotel that it
was not consistent with the definition
of a hotel as set forth in our town code
despite the issuance of the north
violation on Tuesday May 9th New York
City scheduled a debriefing call with
elected officials to tell us that they
would be sending buses the next day they
also described conditions consistent
with a shelter in that there would be
on-site staff available 24 hours a day
seven days a week including one social
worker and one case worker per migrant
for 30 migrants and that New York City
would cover the cost of three meals
laundry service and housekeeping for up
to four months
they also introduced us to the staff
from a company that New York City had
contracted with which specializes in
providing medical related services to
shelters
in light of this the town filed legal
papers in Rockland County Supreme Court
and retained a restraining order against
the hotel uh on on Tuesday May 9th
effectively preventing the use of the
hotel as a shelter and the arrival any
migrants from New York City the next day
to be very clear for our purposes the
immigration status of the individuals is
irrelevant to the town's decision to
seek legal recourse the town sought
legal action to ensure the Integrity of
locals and regulations and the
protection of those who would be housed
in the hotel on a long-term basis as a
shelter as well as the community at
large I also want to outright reject any
charges made that it is an act of
anti-immigration Rockland County is home
to a vibrant immigration immigrant
population and in fact I'm married to
one but over the last two years there's
been a steady increase of migrants
finding their way to Rockland County and
settling in with the support of family
friends and local community groups this
has already started to put a strain on
Rockland County and Rockland County
Department of Social Services so much so
that just over two months ago
Congressman Mike Lawler and County
Executive Ed de held a press conference
and standing with non-profits explained
the financial impacts on Rockland County
the problem with Mr Honor's plan is that
he does not have one that became evident
when during the debriefing call a member
of staff was asked about what would
happen with the migrants at the end of
the four months the response was that
they expected them to integrate into
into the community by that time
but orange town like the rest of New
York state is in a housing crisis
affordability crisis so the question is
how are these men without English skills
without Family Support going to
integrate into our community
so I will tell you what will happen they
will end up renting from a screw
unscrupulous landlords and we know
what's happening because just this past
March there was a tragic house fire in
Rockland that killed five undocumented
immigrants including two children with
five others being hospitalized Orange
and Rockland County just do not have the
resources for stable levels to
investigate and remedy these types of
situations on a wide scale basis
without the federal government acting to
stem the flow of migrants at the border
it was only a matter of time before it
impacted all of our neighborhoods while
it was orange town today it'll be yours
tomorrow thank you and I look forward to
answering questions
thank you and finally we'll hear from
Mrs Tammy Nobles Ms Nobles you've
already heard from several of our
colleagues our hearts go out to you as
to the hearts of every American who
hears your story I know that grief
always feels very alone but I want to
assure you you're not alone and you're
now recognized to tell your story
I um thank you to the members of the
committee for having me my name is Tammy
Nobles I am the mother of Kayla Hamilton
July 24 2002 was one of the best days of
my life
I gave birth to a beautiful baby girl
and named her Kayla Marie
she was a happy and easy going baby even
back then she loved to smile and laugh
she always kept her friends close and
never forgot anyone
she was kind caring thoughtful and funny
she loved life in God
she showed the world that being yourself
was okay and you didn't have to follow
everyone else
sadly on July 27 2022 I received the
worst news that a parent doesn't want to
hear
that my newly 20 20 year old daughter
Kayla Hamilton was murdered in her own
room and left on the floor like trash
she left behind
a mother who loved her a stepfather a
brother a younger sister grandparents
and lots of Aunts Uncles and cousins
at first we knew very little details of
the murder until an arrest was made the
details we learned broke us
at the end of March of 2022 Kayla's
murderer was apprehended by border
patrol Crossing illegally into the U.S
at the Southwest border in Rio Grande
City Texas
I am not sure if he was vetted or not
but he was a sixteen-year-old known gang
member affiliated with MS-13 in El
Salvador the MS-13 Moto is bottle is
kill rape and control
he entered the country as an unoccupied
alien child
as the UAC the murderer was allowed to
go live with his aunt
in Frederick Maryland she was also an
illegal immigrant there were issues with
him living there and he went to go live
with his half-brother who lived in a
same trailer park as Kayla and her
boyfriend my questions are what protocol
was the aunt supposed to follow if she
couldn't handle him then why not inform
the proper authorities
the half brother tried to get him a job
and to do the right thing but that
didn't happen
so the happily told him that he had to
leave at the trailer park an illegal
immigrant owned numerous trailers and
was sub letting them out that is how
Kayla was able to get a place because
she didn't make much and had no credit
yet
the half-brother asked the owner if she
had any rooms for rent she did the same
trailer as Kayla
Kayla's murder was living there in less
than five days before he viciously
murdered my daughter
Kayla had two jobs she was working
at a cleaning company and at a grocery
store
Kayla had autism but she was determined
to live independently and make her way
in this world and my baby paid the
ultimate price
she had just gotten home from work
working the night shift and said goodbye
to her boyfriend that morning when
he left for work she then went to sleep
the murderer went into Kayla's room
strolling her grabbed her iPhone her
iPod charger and wrapped it around her
throat and face while strangling her to
death
Caleb grabbed her phone and called her
boyfriend but went to voicemail
the voicemail of the murderer strangling
her was was two minutes and 30 seconds
long they're murdering them violently
sexually assaulted Kayla
Kayla's boyfriend came home from work
and found her dead on the floor the
charger cord was tight was so tight
around her neck and face that her
boyfriend had to use his teeth to get it
off
the murderer robbed her of her phone in
six dollars six dollars is all my baby
had in cash because she used the snap
machines at work to give something to
eat
he then went to lunch with his
half-brother like nothing happened local
police didn't have enough evidence to
arrest the murderer so Child Protective
Services took him into custody and
placed him in an unsecured children's
home with other children even knowing
that even knowing that he was the main
suspect in a pre-meditated murder case
when he was arrested for Kayla's murder
he laughed and smirked for me this is
not a political issue this is a safety
issue for everyone living in the United
States this could have been anyone's
daughter Kayla wasn't doing anything
wrong and she didn't deserve to be
murdered I don't want any other parent
to live the nightmare that I am
I am her voice now and I'm going to
fight with everything I have to get her
story told and bring awareness of the
issue at the border I will make sure her
memory lives on
murder itself is already a taboo but
then you mentioned MS-13 and nobody
wants to touch it nothing will change if
nobody talks about the problem
the United States government has to
secure our border we need to properly
vet all border crossers the government
could have placed a phone call to
authorities in El Salvador and found out
that he was a gay member but they didn't
if we had stricter border policies my
daughter would still today
nothing will bring my daughter back nor
the pain and
the pain I'm not having her here but I
want it forbidness from happening to
someone else's child
this is about protecting everyone here
in the United States
thank you
we'll now proceed with the five-minute
rule with questions I'm going to defer
mine to the end and recognize Mr Biggs
of Arizona
chairman Ms Nobles thank you again for
being here thank all the witnesses but
thank you for your poignant testimony
I think of
Steve runenbeck
whose son Grant was
murdered as she worked at a
convenience store in Mesa Arizona by an
illegal alien
or Marianne Mendoza
whose son Brandon as a police officer
was killed by an illegal alien in Mesa
Arizona
our heart goes out to you Miss Nobles
I'm stunned that a witness would say we
need to find equilibrium at a time
when 6 million plus people have
illegally entered the country
in the last two years
stunned
I'm stunned to know
that of 31 000 32 000 people
um
21 000 of them were released into the
country over of 72 to 96 hour period
I'm stunned because we don't have
control of our border the CBP Chief or
thesis testified
that the cartels control our border
as has
sector Chief Maudlin of the Tucson
sector as has
sector Chief Chavez of the Rio Grande
Valley sector
I'll go to you Chief Scott
a secretary of my orc has taken the
actions necessary and appropriate to
achieve and maintain operational control
of the borders
absolutely not sir if you listen to uh
the words he said States every time it's
about creating safe Pathways when I was
Chief we were not allowed to even
discuss consequences or actually secure
in the Border it was all about
Expediting the processing and avoiding
the Optics of people backed up into
border patrol stations
the uh
we've heard today
about new parole processes being
implemented
last year over 300 000 people received
parole this year it'll be over 750 000.
prior to the Biden Administration
type that typically you might see 15 to
20 maybe 20 as high as 25
parole processes that's because that's
an individual process even secretary
mayorkas has testified before this
committee that it's an individual
process what has he done
to distort
the parole process Chief Scott
I honestly do not understand how they
can look at the law and do what they're
currently doing with the parole process
by law every one of those approvals is
supposed to be a case-by-case basis it's
supposed to be based on humanitarian
reason or a benefit to the United States
government in my entire time in the
border patrol I probably approved and
I'm estimating about six or eight
paroles a year at the most and those
were usually to benefit a case or
because of some type of a medical
medical condition but there were tight
restrictions put on every one of those
as probably a packet about an inch thick
about keeping track of the individual
because the concept of parole is you're
allowing someone into the United States
that we know does not have a legal right
to be here they haven't proven it so
we're accepting risk on behalf of all of
America that's a heavy burden we all
took that very seriously I I don't I do
not believe the border patrol can be
doing today the legal assessment
required for each individual case it's
just not possible Chief Scott
DHS officials and I'm quoting now from a
New York Times piece
say thousands of migrants are successful
using CBP one instead of paying
Smugglers close quote
is are is that
are you are we to believe that CBP one
is an alternative to cartel smuggling or
are we actually using cbp1 to facilitate
uh cartel smuggling
there's CBP one app is uh from my
understanding is basically a queuing
mechanism like we used to do at ports of
entry with a pen and paper on the South
Side anything that happens on the south
side of that border is definitely
controlled or influenced heavily by the
cartel
anything we can do to get them out of
the system would be fine but I think the
piece that we're missing here too is
we're now
taking away from the legal trade and
travel processes of the CBP officers at
those ports of Entry they were all
gainfully employed prior and the CBP one
app is pushing more and more people into
that Port of Entry that that don't have
by definition do not have a legal right
to be here the other challenge is it's a
magnet because to use the CBP one app
again from my understanding you have to
be in Mexico you have to be up close to
the border so that entices even more
people into that border community and
the throughput does not match the demand
and where does that overage go right
back to the cartels
thank you my times expired
sure now recognizes the ranking member
for five minutes thank you Mr chairman
um Mr Hatfield thank you for your very
compelling testimony as you know one of
the Biden administration's answers to
increased migration at the border is to
expand legal Pathways as title 42 was
set to expire earlier this month the
United States announced its opening of
regional processing centers all over the
hemisphere they will be starting in
Guatemala and Colombia and then
expanding to other countries including
Mexico this seems like a positive step
by the administration to build up its
capacity to take increased numbers of
refugees before they ever even make that
dangerous journey to our Southern border
would you agree with that and what do
you think the United States needs to do
to make these Regional processing
centers a success
yeah I absolutely agree with that I mean
I also agree with with Chief Scott's
assessment uh about the overuse of
parole the administration needs to rely
more on the U.S Refugee admissions
program as a lawful pathway with a
pathway to permanent residence and
ultimately citizenship and suitable
vetting and less on humanitarian parole
and this is definitely a step in the
right direction so I hope those centers
are resourced one of the key strategies
that's going to have to be implemented
though is you have to make those centers
for Asylum Seekers with legitimate
claims more attractive than crossing the
border to seek Asylum so you have to
look at things that have been used in
the past with the refugee program like
the Lautenberg Amendment and apply that
to their applications you have to make
sure that they are applic that their
applications are processed expeditiously
and fairly
um so yes but I'm absolutely supportive
of that measure if you listen to my
colleagues you would think that the the
United States is bearing the brunt of
the global Refugee crisis alone you
highest works all over the world as you
said it's simply not true can you
discuss how other countries in the
hemisphere are seeing significant
increases in the number of Asylum claims
yeah absolutely and it really is a
global Refugee crisis and we are just
one player in this Global Refugee crisis
I mean Colombia alone which was
traditionally a refugee producing
country is now on taking in refugees
millions of Venezuelans to over 2.5
million Venezuelans have sought refuge
in Colombia where highest operates
likewise over 1.5 million in Peru over
half a million in Ecuador
um over nearly half a million in Chile I
mean if you look at every single country
in the hemisphere there are many Asylum
Seekers most of them come from Venezuela
but also from Central America and even
outside of the Western Hemisphere
seeking Asylum and so this really
requires International attention in the
U.S has to lead on this issue and it's
my understanding that highest is
actually helping some of these
individuals apply for asylum in other
countries can you tell us more about
that sure I mean highest is
um number one job is to make Asylum
Seekers safe and secure and welcome
wherever they are and that's in the
first countries to which they flee and
when that fails then we try to find them
third countries but again through safe
and orderly means like Refugee a
resettlement our operations have
expanded massively over the last few
years because of the refugee crisis and
the Venezuelan migration crisis in
particular throughout the Western
Hemisphere
and as you pointed out Refugee uh
Admissions and and the need to assist
refugees has always been a bipartisan uh
concern until recently in fact I
remember uh the testimony of uh somebody
from the national Evangelical
Association
um saying that our Refugee resettlement
program is the is the crown jewel of
humanitarian assistance Mr Hatfield I
wanted to see if you could discuss
misinformation and how it spreads among
migrants who are making the long journey
to the Border can you discuss how rumors
and misinformation spread by the cartels
of an open border impacts the number of
migrants that we see trying to come to
the United States sure and and uh it's
it's it's massive but it's not all
misinformation I mean they're spreading
misinformation and also information
about how broken our border and our
immigration system is and that is an
attractant to people to come in to apply
for uh Asylum and other benefits to
which many of them are not actually
entitled
well thank you Mr Hetfield I couldn't
agree more I think our words matter and
I think that you're pointing out of the
importance of really establishing a
functioning immigration system is
absolutely crucial
um as the ranking member of the full
committee said in his opening statement
it is unfortunately seen as an advantage
by many of our colleagues across the
aisle to leave our immigration system
broken so that we can continue to point
fingers at immigrants who are simply
trying to do what so many of our
forebearers have done come to the United
States because it is a country that has
protected so many people fleeing
terrible persecution and many other ills
I thank you for your testimony today and
for being with us I yield back Mr
chairman
a chair recognizes Mr Tiffany Wisconsin
for five minutes thank you Mr chairman
chief Scott isn't it correct that many
of these people are not Asylum Seekers
that they're actually not legitimate
asylees that is that is very accurate
most of them when you ask them questions
their uh their economic refugees of
anything they're seeking uh work isn't
it isn't it correct when remain in
Mexico was in place under the previous
administration there was over 90 percent
that rejected they were not legitimate
asylees that is correct and that also
acted as a deterrent so people stopped
coming to the Border because they knew
they couldn't get away with fraud yeah
just for the record Mr chairman I was
down at the daring Gap two years ago at
this time in May and that's exactly what
we heard people were coming they were
like we had resettled to Chile and we
were perfectly happy there we resettled
to Brazil Haitians others of Venezuelans
they said we were perfectly happy there
but since you're going to open the
Border we're going to come to the United
States of America that's not a
legitimate Asylum claim is it that is
not
uh with secretary mayorkas has he done
his job to protect the American people
I do not believe that he has he's
focused on the processing and completely
ignored border security which by the way
actually decimates our immigration
system Goods border security supports
our good immigration system
uh Mrs Nobles if border policies
continue as they are over the last two
years will there be more Kalos
yes I believe so
and that is why I'm getting trying to
get her story out so people are aware of
the issue
might Kayla be alive if the Biden
administration had secured the Border
over the last two years
yes I believe she would still be here if
he was properly vetted
would you prefer from us if you had a
choice to get condolences from Members
which I'm sure are very heartfelt would
you prefer condolences or would you
prefer changes in the law like to secure
the Border Act
I was like oh sorry I would like to have
changes in
the law
and I want to I want it I want to put a
law in Kayla's name
um to help you know to have her memory
live on into the to those will know that
she was the one that could you know that
changed the law unfortunately Mr
chairman we have a name for these people
angel families and that is a horrible
thing here in America that we have such
a thing that we have to name all those
people that have been killed by people
who came in here illegally into our
country
um I want to go back to you Mr Scott
um have you had a chance to see the
grand jury presentment in Florida have
you reviewed that I have not reviewed it
in this entirety now
um would it surprise you out of that
presentment a 24 year old male was
processed by or the office of refugee
resettlement and went on to violently
kill his sponsor by uh stabbing him 50
times would it be surprised that that
person was came in as a minor but
actually was a 24 year old male is that
surprising to you it is not surprising
I'm I'm familiar with that case there's
no database that we can check people's
ages off of so you have to go with their
word would you be surprised out of that
presentment that many don't carry any
form of identification or authentic IDs
I'm not surprised usually they get rid
of it before they cross the board are
you are you surprised that uac's
unaccompanied alien children are not
rapid DNA tested or biometric tested to
be honest they're not even fingerprinted
and photographed in many occasions if
they're under 14 so no
would you be surprised to know out of
that presentment that most case managers
at or do not have any special training
and many have been hired over the phone
sight unseen with a very cursory
approach
that's very troubling but unfortunately
I'm not surprised would you be surprised
that agents in the El Paso region
discovered more than 665 adult illegal
aliens in 2021 alone who tried to pose
as unaccompanied minors to gain
expedited entry into the United States
in the past 12 months I'm not surprised
anytime you carve out a special group
people try to take advantage of that and
lie and get into it would you be
surprised if any or attorney the office
of refugee and resettlement
stated we only get sued for keeping them
too long we don't get sued by
traffickers
I'm not surprised not as consistent with
what I was told and heard during my time
as Chief in this Administration thank
you to all the member of the people that
are here today I would just close we
heard all kinds of data from the ranking
member here in his presentation over the
course of three decades about I believe
it added up to about 233 000 people came
in Via parole that was over the course
of three decades we've had over a
million people come in Mr chairman in
just a little over two years that is not
Humane in any way
terrorists human traffickers and
Fentanyl poisonings are a product of
what has happened under the Biden
Administration and secretary mayorkas I
yield back chair now recognizes Mr
Nadler for five minutes thank you Mr
chairman Mr Hadfield our Republican
colleagues use a lot of inflammatory
rhetoric calling migrants arriving at
the southern bordering Invasion can you
discuss the impact this kind of language
has on the work that you and hires do
yeah that's a difficult topic it's had a
significant impact especially as a as a
Jewish agency
um first of all there's the the
vilification of undocumented immigrants
and Asylum Seekers which is having a
major impact on
um
on the agency on security issues
regarding the agency and on
relationships with the people that we
deal with the vast majority of Asylum
Seekers are coming here because they are
fleeing persecution
um many people who come here are not in
need of protection but that's why we
need we need a system that makes that
distinction
um we don't have one right now but in
terms of highest itself
unfortunately the theory of replacement
theory is gaining more and more
mainstream attention which is that there
is a conspiracy
um of
by Jews and others to bring in
um brown people and non-Christian people
to replace white Christian Americans
This is becoming a serious problem uh
for us it's gaining more and more
mainstream acceptance and
um I'm not really sure what to do with
that
thank you the United States along with
others in the hemisphere recently signed
the Los Angeles Los Angeles Declaration
of migration and protection as part of
the Declaration the United States
committed to taking 20 000 refugees over
the next two years from the hemisphere
this feels like a start but seems wholly
inadequate given that seven million
people are displaced from Venezuela
alone would you agree and can the United
States be doing more to take refugees
from the hemisphere
yeah absolutely we're very late to that
as I said many other countries are
accepting um many Venezuelans and much
larger numbers than we are through more
efficient processes
and Venezuelans now make up the number
one population in the United States for
Asylum Seekers I mean it is a
hemispheric problem that needs a
hemispheric solution and we need to be
part of that strategy and and accepting
more through the refugee resettlement
program again a safe and orderly program
is the best way to go
thank you can you discuss how the United
States stepping up stepping up its
Refugee program can have a positive
impact on the number of Asylum Seekers
we see at the U.S border right it needs
to be done
um a in conjunction with having an
asylum system that gives uh that's
efficient and that gives responses uh
quickly and makes decisions quickly but
it provides a safe and legal pathway for
people who need protection and therefore
discourages them from taking their lives
at risk trying to cross the border to
get that protection
um it's it's absolutely a necessary
safety valve and uh and legal pathway
and unfortunately the Biden
Administration has not yet succeeded in
rebuilding that program as you know uh
the the refugee resettlement admissions
ceiling last year was 125 000 and we
fell 100 000 short of that
thank you barriers to work authorization
have devastating consequences for
arriving migrants in local communities
which is one reason there has been
bipartisan support for improving access
to work permits and addressing lengthy
processing backlogs what does Congress
and the administration need to do to
support local employers and improve
access to work authorization
well uh this is a really vexing problem
where Asylum Seekers are not allowed to
ex not allowed to accept employment nor
are they allowed to receive any
assistance while their Asylum
application is pending for a minimum of
six months in many cases it's much much
longer than that so basically they have
to find a way to support themselves and
there are no legal means for doing so so
that is a system that is destined to
fail the H.R 1325 the Asylum Seeker work
authorization Act of 2023 does provide a
solution so I would urge that that or
similar measures be be supported thank
you my final question is um we heard the
story of uh
the the the
um
the person who murdered uh
Mrs Noble's daughter now uh
this person I gather was a came in as an
unaccompanied minor
um has any change been made
between the Trump and Biden
administrations that would have affected
the ability of an unaccompanied minor to
come into this country and and what he
would do afterwards
um I mean many changes have been made uh
by the by the administration that the
Trump Administration was as you know uh
pushing minors back uh at the border so
um but but the bottom line is that this
goes back to the other parts of my
testimony which is that we need a system
where control does not stop at the
border but continues into the United
States so right now we're not properly
resourcing the system to do that
including
um as the New York Times recently
exposed with regard to the treatment of
of unaccompanied minors thank you thank
you my time has expired I yield back Mr
van Drew
thank you Mr chairman
well here we go again addressing the
continued policy failures of this
Administration
at the border
and as our border descends further into
chaos I can't help but worry that this
nation is becoming increasingly
comfortable comfortable with accepting
weakness not accepting the rule of law
and accepting it all as our new normal
an acceptance of weakness that led to
the highest number of Border Encounters
in a single day ever and by the way
there was a comment from somebody from
the other side and they said that you
know Republicans enjoy this because they
can use it as political fodder let's be
clear the Democrats were in control for
two years they had the presidency they
had the Senate they had the House of
Representatives they could have done
anything they could have made this
better they could have straightened it
out it wasn't a split
but they didn't that's the reality so
let's talk about what's really true and
that's not just talk political talk that
doesn't make sense
an acceptance of weakness has turned
every town in America from El Paso Texas
to Orange County California and I'm
sorry New York into a de facto Border
Town an acceptance of weakness that has
turned public parks police stations and
school gymnasiums into makeshift
shelters
tell me that's good for America anybody
sitting out there right now you tell me
that that's good for our America an
acceptance of weakness that led to the
tragic case of Kayla Hamilton where an
MS-13 gang member was allowed into our
country as a supposed quote
unaccompanied minor end quote despite a
history of criminal activity and of
violence tell me that's good for our
America
if you have strong borders if you don't
have strong borders excuse me you are
not a strong Nation every country in the
world basically has strong borders third
world countries have stronger borders
than we do right now
if this Administration cannot protect
its citizens
they are not worthy of the authority
Americans have trusted them with
and personally I do not think that
secretary mayorkus is Worthy
and I do not think our president is
if you continue to accept the weakness
we are witnessing you are surrendering
the very foundations of our democracy
the disregard for our laws we're not a
nation of the rule of law anymore think
about the premise in which we argue
discuss and debate this it's against the
law to illegally enter the country it's
against the law you've broken the law
I don't understand why the law doesn't
matter anymore are we a nation of laws
or are we not
that's the important question here
it's gone so out of hand that our
secretary mayorkas is celebrating
actually celebrating 6300 illegal
encounters as a good day
that's a good day think about that
President Obama's homeland security
secretary once claimed that a thousand
encounters a day would be a crisis
but now 6 300 is a good day
today it's a Triumph this is the
acceptance of weakness consuming our
nation and it threatens the safety and
well-being of each and every American
and we should not tolerate it and we
should change it you can be a Humane and
good country but still believe in the
rule of law
and I wonder I wonder how Kayla's family
feels about it all
I wonder if she thinks this is good I
have three quick questions for chief
Scott with the number of Crossings our
country is experiencing can border
patrol properly debrief and access the
information and intentions of every
migrant trying to come across our border
yes or no no
thank you do you believe it is easy for
a terrorist to get into the United
States undetected today than five years
ago yes or no it definitely is thank you
as thousands of illegal migrants are
accepted into our country every day are
there there are less obvious threats to
Americans that we aren't noticing yet or
are we looking into them enough the
question is are we looking into these
threats enough yes or no no the border
patrol barely has time to process who's
in custody they're leaving hundreds of
miles of border on patrol every day
exactly this is and thank you sir thank
you for your work this is a joke
let's really talk about the real issue
it's the rule of law it's the safety of
our people we're breaking the law and
we're becoming weaker and we've got to
stop it
thank you chairman I yield back chairman
yields back and chair recognizes Mr
Korea of California
thank you Mr chairman first of all Ms
Nobles I also want to express my
condolences as a fellow parent
I also have a daughter at the same age
at your daughter
uh two years ago I got a phone call at
home I should say it worked from home
my daughter was all alone at home
called me screaming crying saying Daddy
there's two men in the house
two men were burglarizing the house
what do I do daddy and I said stay by
the dogs
let me call 9-1-1
and I those moments of Terror I hate to
think what would have happened if those
German Shepherds weren't there
or if our local Santa Ana PD had not
gotten there in minutes
ma'am I can guarantee you that no one
condones
criminals in our streets without without
documents
this is about our families and the
safety of our families widowed without
documents I do not condone any money in
our streets that would harm our families
Miss Noble my prayers are with your
family
and Mr chair without objection I like to
submit for the record this Wall Street
Journal article entitled what everyone
except the USA has learned about
immigration is Washington sits divided
our Global Rivals lower their barriers
to East labor shortages
Mr chairman
that's right uh without objection
Mr Hadfield if I may
covid the aftermath of covet
it seems that the USA is again the
world's economic locomotive the world
seems to be devastated economically even
the Great China
even the grad economy is sputtering
right now
I got a phone call the other day from
the president of Guatemala
asking for help with the refugee
challenge Guatemala is facing
you mentioned Colombia 2.4 to Venezuelan
refugees
Mexico is having a challenge
this is a worldwide phenomena you've
already addressed it but I want you to
again repeat is this a U.S challenge at
this moment we can look at this last two
or three years and say this is
this is wrong but you've got to open it
up Beyond just the US it's a worldwide
phenomen am I correct or not
yeah you're absolutely correct I mean
the United States cannot solve this
problem alone but we're not going
through it alone either
um the and the global Refugee the global
Refugee crisis is over 120 million
people right now
I I I'm always tempted to say this is a
refugee challenge like we haven't seen
since World War II when 60 million
Europeans were on the move
am I correct in that assessment
yeah I mean the actual number is is
double that in terms of a forcibly
displaced persons uh so you're you're
not incorrect at all it's a proportion
of the world population of course it's
smaller but in in absolute numbers it's
double
Chief Scott if I may ask you a question
sir I want to say first of all you you
were doing an impossible job
thank you for what you're doing
you know
the private sector in our society
continues to be a magnet for workers
60 percent of the individuals that come
across
blend into society they have families
they ride with they blend into society
fifty percent of our Farm Workers are
undocumented I would say that as long as
we don't have immigration reform that is
sensible that works for a private sector
the need for workers in this country is
also a magnet would you say that or not
I started out in immigration
Naturalization Service where I was
taught border security supports our
legal immigration system so that we can
meet needs like that they do go hand in
hand but I do point out that if you
can't control the flow in any way
then you really can't in any kind of
numbers or any kind of decisions you put
at the other end are irrelevant
um I I do believe this country was based
on immigration I think everybody in the
border patrol supports immigration
that's why they got in but we support it
legally and I agree with you the problem
is there is no way to get into work in
this country right now
our economy would suffer again 50
percent of our Farm Workers being
undocumented I don't think anybody
supports a policy to deport those
workers because that would affect our
food security but I look forward to
working with all of you
and making sure we do some common sense
reforms that are good for the American
economy and the American people thank
you very much Mr chair I yield
Mr chairman
purpose does the gentlelady seek
recognition have a unanimous consent
request
to enter the following statements into
the record organizational statements
from the center for gender and Refugee
studies Church World Service and
National Immigration Form without
objection thank you chair now recognizes
Mr Roy of Texas
I think the chairman Mr Scott we were
just told that we're unable to get
Workers into this country true or false
we get somewhere around a million green
cards every year and we have seasonal
workers are able to come here and work
under our current system under the law
that's correct and currently at our
border what do we have right now in
terms of our ability for border patrol
to stop the flow between ports of Entry
or our or is it in fact that border
patrol is processing people at the ports
of Entry
the border patrol stays outside the
ports of Entry themselves but the border
patrol is literally it's almost acting
as a port because they're processing
getaways and they're leaving hundreds of
miles of Border wide open for example at
a tent like in uh Eagle Pass right where
you've got a 10 acre facility where
you're processing 1500 people a day it's
border patrol part of that operation yes
sir as opposed to actually being on the
line and being able to go Patrol the
border between the boards of entries as
they're supposed to do correct and
there's been some numbers reported but I
think what's important is even if half
of the border patrol agents are deployed
to the field at the beginning to shift
within an hour or so they're overwhelmed
with thousands of more illegal aliens
and then they are processing as well
leaving the Border wide open Chief Scott
do we know how much fentanyl or
dangerous narcotics come in between our
ports of Entry or dangerous individuals
we have no idea but there's no shortage
in Chicago or New York right so this
claim by my colleagues on the side of
the aisle that all of the fentanyl comes
in at the ports of Entry we literally
don't know how much is coming in between
the board's Adventure because border
patrol is unable to do its job while
it's being overwhelmed by the failed
policies of this Administration is that
true that is accurate and if you look at
the statistics anytime illegal
immigration across the border between
the ports slows down drug seizures
actually increase because agents are
actually out there identifying it
supervisor Kenny you your community has
been dramatically impacted right by the
number of of individuals that have been
dumped into your community can you
quickly it's just a matter of time
explain how much that is negatively
impacted your community
uh I'm from Orange town in Rockland
County we actually obtained a
restraining order to to prevent them
from coming until it goes through the
court system the county just north of us
has received um hundreds and hundreds at
this point and I I can't speak for them
um and you have had uh hotels filled up
with like single often single males that
are filling up places so the needy
individuals aren't able to get
facilities and they aren't able to get
the resources they need is that true
yeah the goal of uh mayor Adams was to
send 340 single adult men to a hotel in
my town it's been put on hold by the
courts and where is your town again in
Orange town which is uh 30 miles north
of New York City okay so not on the
southern border of the United States no
um and so this is something we're
dealing with as my friend from Arizona
Mr Biggs knows we're and my friend from
California Mr McClintock and others know
On the Border we deal with it all the
time in our communities in South Texas
but this is something that the entire
country is now dealing with and I'd like
to now move to Ms Nobles and I cannot
possibly put into words Ms Nobles what
you have experienced as a result of the
failed policies of this country
um I would simply ask
as carefully as I can having met with
numerous
family members who have lost loved ones
due to these failed policies whether
it's through violence as you have
unfortunately experienced or whether it
is through for example fentanyl
poisonings that so many of our moms have
experienced I met with three fentanyl
moms just two weeks ago in Austin Texas
I've met met with dozens I've met with
dozens of individuals who've lost loved
ones including a family member in San
Antonio whose son was killed by an
illegal immigrant who had been here had
been arrested let go arrested let go and
then burned this woman's son to death
that's what we have going on in our
country while our colleagues on the
other side of the aisle Barry they're
heading to sand and pretend that somehow
it's compassionate I would just ask you
Ms Nobles to explain uh whether or not
you've had interactions with other moms
and family members who have had similar
unfortunate experiences as a result of
our failed policies
um unfortunately I have it I haven't
seen any body talk about
their story or shared anything about you
know what you know if you know because I
know it
um Kayla wasn't the only one
where are they like
so that's why I'm standing up and
talking about her story and getting her
story out at least I can speak for my
child and make sure that I make people
aware of what's going on well Ms Nobles
I'm going to after this hearing uh
connect you with angel families who've
had a number of these experience that
they've put out with the Vargas family
in San Antonio who have been dealing
with it with loss from from these kinds
of policies and I would just ask uh
Chief Scott are the current policies
stopping stopping uh the kind of
violence that can occur through having
for example in this case a UAC an
unaccompanied alien child who ended up
carrying out this crime that Ms Nobles
had to suffer from I want to ask you
that question but I also just want to
point out and before you answer the
question and then I'll I'll yield back
I just came back from the Federal
District Courthouse because I went over
there to support Jaime Zapata's family
because Jaime Zapata was gunned down by
the cartels in 2011 and the sentencing
is going on right now as we speak
cartels are empowered in our border
they're empowered by China they are
empowered by Our Own federal government
failing to do its job and Americans are
dying as a result and so are migrants Mr
Scott if you can answer that question
then I'll yield back the current crisis
is making it impossible to be able to
weed out the criminals especially the
uacs from anyone else the agents don't
have time to do face-to-face interviews
there's no Global like database of
criminal records
thank you Chief Scott
Mr chairman
I seek unanimous consent on various
articles to put peace from The New York
Times dated April 23rd Biden opens a new
back door on immigration
the Navajo Nation requesting answers to
questions
border crossings down this is Washington
Post article from May 19 border
crossings down but many migrants
released to U.S to ease crowding
Breitbart peace
entitled human Smuggler drops
pre-school-aged child over California
border wall dated today's date as well
as a piece dated Today George Democrat
slams party for favoring migrants over
Americans without objection
thank you chair now recognizes Miss
Jackson Lee of Texas
chairman into the ranking member uh
as one would expect
um
it's Nobles and I'm over here it's
Nobles I'm in this direction
um as a mother I couldn't say anything
less than
the pain
that I know that you're experiencing I
could say my heart goes out to you but
I want to acknowledge the pain
for any mother any family to lose their
precious child
I want your daughter's story to be heard
and if we can work in a bipartisan way I
will sign on to any bill
that enhances her heroic story
I think that's what you
are surviving on
what a young woman wanting to be
independent working two jobs
holding her head up high
a vicious Act
forgive me
if I say
this is not solely immigration poor
police work to be honest with you
but frankly we wanted that not to happen
and no one's panel is Champion MS-13 I
can tell you that
and so we've got to find a way
to decipher discern to weed out
because if there is a mother trying to
come
with just to to work in the fields
I know that
that may not be the best way for her to
come but that is not the MS-13 they
don't deserve to be in this country
period
so let me just
I don't want to say thank you because
you're here in pain but just want you to
know I think her story
has to be told thank you for your
presence here today
Chief I assume we served
overlapping I'm not sure what years were
you you're retired so what years have
you served sir as the chief it was 20 20
February 2020 until August of 2021 but I
was border patrol Asian for over 29
years it's starting what year
1992. yeah so you've had several
um
leaders presidents and then of course
Homeland Security came into being after
9 11. I was on the committee in its
Origins and know just about every one of
your border patrol leaders
um would you say that it would be better
to approach immigration reform
Republicans and Democrats in a
terminology that we've coined under the
late John McCain comprehensive
immigration reform which in essence
deals with border security on the North
and the South and recognizing legal
Pathways for uh entry would you ex would
you accept that would be a better
approach I believe border security is
exactly like your home it gets over
complicated a lot of times when the
public discussion but it's exactly like
your home we just need people to come
through the front door in a legal manner
Congress gets to pick who those people
are not the border patrol so my time is
short I want you to answer the question
specifically comprehensive immigration
reform with border security and legal
Pathways would you accept that based on
my experience of border security has to
come first well let me I can't put words
in your mouth but you're not going to
get border security coming first you
need to be able to balance it you would
not accept a border security and
recognizing Pathways to Legal entry
based on my experience and looking at 86
Ira you have to be able to secure the
Border first
yeah I appreciate that I think
reasonably Mr Hatfield as you understand
when John McCain the late John McCain we
had a very strong comprehensive bill
and it had border security
and the legal pathway if we get stuck on
border security we're not listening to
the witnesses here we're not listening
to uh the New York uh town that is
frustrated with what's happening to them
rightly so so let me just uh get you to
this espouse because my time is going
first of all your organization was
affiliated with the tree of life was it
not
or that the attitude of that killer yeah
I'd rather not discuss the tree of life
because the prosecution is ongoing at
this point well let me just say since I
went there uh let me just say that the
attitude was that Jews were bringing in
uh migrants and immigrants is that true
that is correct and it resulted in death
did it not that is correct all right let
me just get to the point of the work
that you do
um and that is
um if things change in the hemisphere so
that more refugees are coming and you
work with refugees to help the United
States so they don't result in being
lost or being in the wrong direction and
as well I would assume that you abhor
MS-13 as well if you can answer those
two questions I'd appreciate it
absolutely and absolutely you got to say
yes yes is entirely focused on legal
Pathways to bring people into the United
States so they do not resort to fleeing
across borders to seek Asylum we try to
provide them with safe and legal
alternatives to that and uh in
partnership with the US government and
Jewish communities and absolutely we
need a system of control which can
identify that and and detain and and
reject and remove people who are danger
to the society the gentle ladies like
MS-13
all the witnesses for being here today
you know I've said this before and I'll
say it again at a closed border a
control border is actually a
compassionate border and not just for
the migrants to get turned in injured
servants
or worse but for the Americans
that some of these illegal aliens harm
for example in my district in second
congressional district of Alabama a
couple weeks ago Autauga County Sheriff
Department arrested gravy Zavala the 29
year old illegal alien from Honduras for
the rape of a teenage girl in Prattville
it's alleged that he drug her into a
bathroom in a restaurant
um press reports indicate that he
entered the United States in November
through Texas using a fake name what was
allowed to enter into this country in
addition according to the Press reports
he had a criminal record in Honduras
I don't know how this is possibly
acceptable Ms Nobles unfortunately you
and your family know this all too well
and I am terribly sorry for what
happened to you and your daughter I'm
proud father of four I got two girls and
a granddaughter that'll be born probably
by Friday I understand that's what the
experts say anyway we should never let
this happen and so Mr Hetfield I want to
kind of go to you initially you you said
we got a lot of people coming to this
country that are not qualified what do
you mean by that
the um the the only way for many people
to come into this country is through the
Asylum system that's the only way to be
able to um not be expeditiously removed
at the border is to claim a fear so of
course people are being uh are using
that pathway if they're coming here for
reasons that do not qualify them for
Asylum such as
um they they need to support themselves
they're trying to escape poverty they're
trying to reunite with family which is
why we need to have an asylum system
that that functions and efficiently
determines whether or not somebody has a
legitimate Asylum claim or not Mr
Hempfield let me ask you this I was in
Yuma Arizona we had this is our third
here and we had one in the district in
Yuma actually on the border and uh the
sheriff's informed us there that uh
basically they're just the Border agents
have become concierge they're just
giving these people motion to appear an
taxpayer-funded subsidy in a cell phone
and then when we take their calls for
court dates they're not they're not
they'll take our phones but they're not
taking our calls do you find that
alarming that we're just turning people
loose with very little background checks
um I find it very alarming that people
are getting lost in the system waiting
for years to get an asylum hearing that
doesn't work for anybody speaking of
Lost in the system we we heard a few
weeks ago that we had lost 85 000
unaccompanied minors the federal
government had shipped them to Google
addresses in America and now it sounds
like based on testimony they're not all
minors and they're actually some of them
here are doing a great deal of harm uh
Mr Scott I want to ask you a question
real quick
um you know I heard prices uh people had
on their heads for coming to this
country just South of the Border last
time I heard it's about six or seven
thousand dollars come out of Mexico
further south triangle Nations about
nine or ten thousand dollars and then
Syria was twenty thousand dollars
Russians were paying nineteen thousand
dollars in Chinese Nationals were paying
eighty thousand dollars where is that
money going you think Mr yeah goes
directly to fuel the cartels
it feels our the cartel and what happens
if somebody doesn't have the money do
they actually become endangered servants
or slaves is that what happens so that
is one of the many things that could
happen the prices vary depending on how
much risk you're willing to take how far
out the desert should go so they vary
but the the price also varies if you're
willing to do other things so if you're
willing to guide or you're willing to
smuggle narcotics or you know I heard
that that's interesting Mr Scott I
appreciate you mentioning that that they
actually if you'll backpack that heroin
and cocaine or fentanyl your passage is
somewhat considered paid if you're
willing to be a drug mule rather than a
slave is that correct that is how some
people cross yes
Ms Nobles have you heard anything from
the Biden Administration concerning the
loss of your daughter no I haven't
thank you thank you Mr chairman with
that I'm going to yield back General
Mills back after what purpose does Miss
Jackson Lee seek recognition uh I'd like
to ask unanimous consent that I can
submit into the record article Biden
emits I'm sorry my Administration to
send 1 500 troops to the southern border
uh for support
um roles ahead of expected migrant and
also to have a statement that reflects
that the numbers have gone down as it
relates to those entering the United
States at this time astronautious
consent without objection and the chair
recognizes Ms Ross
um thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you to all of the witnesses and in
particular to Mrs Nobles for um sharing
your story and please know that I join
with my colleagues in wanting Justice
for her and for other people who have
similarly lost their lives through
senseless senseless acts and um please
know we're with you
um this is earlier this spring and the
ranking member may have brought this up
in her opening comments we traveled
um to McAllen and Brownsville Texas to
Texas border towns our conversations
with U.S custom and Border Protection
during that visit reinforce my
commitment to ensuring that CBP has the
resources that it needs to strengthen
border control
agents we spoke with specifically
emphasized the need for sophisticated
surveillance technology to monitor
border crossings they talked about how
the cartels had more drones and kids on
roofs who were operating the drones than
the kinds of technology that we needed
to see people before they got to the
border and be able to stem that and I
see that Chief Scott is nodding as I
talked about that during our visit it I
was also struck by the Reliance of our
immigration and Asylum systems on
non-profits in local governments that
they were not getting the support from
the federal government or the state
governments to do their jobs and what
goes on in Brownsville Texas on the
local government tax dollars is nothing
short of extraordinary to make sure that
people who have been allowed to cross
the border can get on their way quickly
and not be in Brownsville and not be in
those hotels they say they don't want
people to stay overnight in Brownsville
they want to get people to the bus
station they want to get people to the
airport
now while their work is admirable
um this responsibility shouldn't fall
solely on ngos and local governments
state and federal governments need to
bolster the resources dedicated to
responding to this many people who enter
the United States under Asylum claims
and through other legal Pathways and the
federal government must fund the
technology that CBP needs and the
training and the Personnel so that they
can do their jobs
immigration is an extremely complex
issue and Democrats are pushing for
implementation of effective solutions to
strengthen border security and expand
legal legal Pathways to enter this
country it is important that we expand
legal Pathways because we simply need
the workers and I represent North
Carolina I hear from the agriculture
industry every day I went to visit a
small family farm
two weeks ago number one issue
immigration hospitality industry number
one issue immigration tech industry
number one issue immigration we need to
do both
in fact
we need to make sure that our rhetoric
doesn't make the immigration problems
worse and unfortunately it's been
documented that repeated right-wing
claims about the Border being completely
open are used on social media by
Smugglers to encourage more people
to attempt to come to the United States
without authorization we need to have
that stopped we need to put aside our
partisan blinders and use these hearings
not to magnify the problems of our
immigration system but to solve them in
a bipartisan way
with the remaining minute I have my
first question is for Mr Hetfield
unlike many countries ours does not have
a reception system for Asylum Seekers
after they've been initially processed
by immigration officials at the border
and allowed to come into our country
ngos and local governments like
Brownsville Texas are stepping in to
fill the Gap that the federal and state
governments have left
and we need we simply need a more
orderly process I wish everybody could
see how well Brownsville does its job
from your experience how are these
programs contributing to a safe and
orderly immigration system and what more
can be done in 14 seconds
they're they're absolutely essential
when I directed the U.S Commission on
International religious freedoms uh
study on expedited removal a few years
ago we did find that when you provide
that kind of counseling you actually
have a very high dissolve rate by Asylum
Seekers because they realize that
they're actually not eligible for the
benefit so they withdraw their claims
but but by not having reception system
you're just contributing to having
people get lost in the system
thank you Mr chairman and I yield back
chair recognizes Mr nails of Texas
thank you Mr chairman Miss Nobles uh
thank you for your testimony today I I
can't imagine I have three daughters 20
to 17 and 10. I can't imagine what you
and your family have been going through
and like so many other families across
the United States I'm just I'm
incredibly sorry for your loss
um Chief Rodney Scott thank you for
being here I had the opportunity to
review the case File this is the case
file on this this murderer this
well I'ma stop with that on this alleged
a 17 year old unaccompanied alien child
who brutally killed and raped Kayla
Hamilton I know you're familiar sir
you're familiar with the intake forms
record of the portable inadmissible
aliens this is the form here so I'm
going to walk through a few things that
I noticed that I saw in this form that
this this
bad ombre
said his intended location was Texas and
as we know he then went to Maryland he
didn't stay in Texas didn't stay there
very long
this bad ombre said he had no funds in
his possession and that his father was
his method of support and as we know he
somehow was moved to live with his aunt
this bad hombre said he was claiming
credible fear credible fear like
everybody up there we know that a
majority of those claims are
unsubstantiated I think it's about 10
percent but later said on his HHS intact
form that he had come to work so he's a
liar he's a bad ombre and a lion wanted
that
the UAC said he had no prior criminal
history
no prior criminal history however after
his arrest Maryland law enforcement
think about that we can't count on the
federal government down at the border to
make sure that the people entering our
country are decent people that that
don't have criminal records but it took
local and state law enforcement in
Maryland
one phone call to El Salvador that's it
get on the phone I call El Salvador I
said hey let me ask you about this bad
hombre that entered our country was did
he has he been arrested and they say oh
yes oh yes sir he's been arrested in El
Salvador in 2020 for his illicit
Association within MS-13 gangs couldn't
figure that out down at the border we
got to find out after he kills and rapes
and murders a young woman in the United
States
he said he was 16 he wasn't 16. had no
Pro reform you don't you need to prove
your age you just say I'm 16. well we
were in a case here a couple uh month or
so ago about the gentleman that comes
through he claims he was uh UAC he goes
to Florida with his caretaker and
butchers the guy in Florida I saw a
picture of this guy he had more chin
whiskers than the witness next to you
he's 25 years old he came in as an
unaccompanied alien child how does that
work how does that happen
how why do we have more safety guards
safety reels down at our Southern border
so we were able to establish this man or
a chief any of the 380 000 uacs that
have entered since Joe Biden took office
were under the age of 18. how are we
able to determine whether they're
actually truly under 18. we really can't
sir that's where a seasoned professional
agent comes in when they interview them
a lot of those inconsistencies you
talked about come up in the story
immediately but the chaos that we have
on the border today prevents the agents
from having that amount of time the
administration is yelling at them to
process and move them down the assembly
line is pop so when the secretary my
orcas gets on front of the camera and
lies to the American people every other
day if not daily and he says these
people are vetted is that a true
statement sir they're vetted against a
blank sheet of paper there's no Global
database to vet them off of what kind of
a border what kind of a background check
is done
and and these individuals They're ran
through a United States governments well
ncic which runs through criminal
databases but unless the individuals
have been in the United States committed
a crime here before it's not going to be
in that system
you know I've said it before I'll say it
again this is number three I think third
hearing on the on the border all Joe
Biden had to do when he was inaugurated
on January 21 I I sat I went there I
respect the Office of the President all
he had to do was keep his mouth shut he
didn't have to say anything about our
Southern border and we'd be a much more
safe country today March 12 2021 I have
a report hold it up following a
reassessment to see DC director
terminated title 42 with respect to
unaccompanied Alien Children if I'm
understanding this correctly is it true
that for the last two years we created a
blanket waiver to allow anyone claiming
to be under 18 into United States
despite their criminal records or
gaining affiliation yes or no I believe
the gang affiliation if they know they
could still Deport him but for the most
part that parents let's be clear MS-13
stands for kill rape control and Joe
Biden as Secretary of Americas are
allowing potentially 30 year old gang
members into our communities into our
schools and around our kids where they
will do the exact damn thing they did to
Kayla Hamilton shame on them and we must
hold them accountable I yield back
for what purpose is a gentlelady from
Washington seek recognition Mr chairman
I ask unanimous consent that the
following be made a part of the record
this is an email that was sent yesterday
by the Department of Health and Human
Services reminding my colleagues that
HHS allowed committee staff an in-camera
review of this the individual the
unaccompanied minors file with the
expectation that the committee would
refrain from disclosing any non-public
information it obtained it is imperative
that we do not interfere with the
Integrity of criminal proceedings I
would hope that my colleagues would not
disclose any information that could
impact the criminal proceedings or Miss
Noble's ability to get Justice for her
daughter it was a serious violation
without objection that will be entered
into the record thank you Mr chairman uh
I'll next uh recognize myself for five
minutes
um supervisor Kenny again 3.6 million
illegal immigrants entering this country
over the past 28 months Gallup by the
way told us last year they're estimating
uh in Latin American Caribbean alone 42
million people intend to come here now
that the borders are open what's this
doing due to to the situation in your
homeless shelters or in your food
pantries and what are you hearing from
other cities in New York
yeah so as we've I've learned in recent
weeks
um we already have a lot of migrants
finding their way to to Rockland County
through family and friends and it's
already putting a burden on our social
services and our Rockland County
um so much so that they recently had to
give another million dollars to the food
pantries keeping in mind that mayor
Adams got eight uh he got eight uh I'm
sorry he got a billion dollars from New
York State and um and he is looking to
put them in hotels in in our town
without any support or or any um what
are your constituents telling you
the constituents have concerns and I see
I sit here today and I hear this
testimony and I understand why
um there was questions raised about were
the individuals going to be vetted and
they were told us that they would be
vetted at the border so in in light of
what I'm hearing today it gives pause
for the questions about who you see in
our community thank you Chief Scott one
of our colleagues said that you you had
an impossible job
um was your job impossible when we were
actually enforcing our immigration laws
it was not impossible and we were
getting better at it every single day
and we had a strategy to actually secure
the Border but it's basically become
impossible since Biden changed those
policies is that correct correct the
current flow of illegal immigration will
exceed any ability to be able to see
when Mr Biden canceled work on the
border wall did that not also cancel
work on the technology at the border to
detect illegal Crossings it did that and
it also shut off our new Communications
capability that was being built into the
wall system as well under the
immigration Naturalization Act foreign
Nationals claim Asylum are required to
be detained until their claim is heard
are they no
um what can you tell us about cartel and
gang activity uh being introduced into
our country over the past two years
so everything that crosses that
Southwest border now is controlled by
the cartels the cartels control the
illegal migrant Crossings so that they
can create these gaps in border security
and then they smuggle when I say gaps in
border security I mean they overwhelm
all the law enforcement in the area
Beyond border patrol and then that opens
gaps where there's no law enforcement
and they bring anything they want into
the country behind that even on the U.S
side if it's narcotics or even aliens
they are basically facilitated or guided
to their ultimate destinations through
cartel on this side and very very very
tight ties with many of the gangs MS-13
and others you can't really tell where
the cartel ends and where they don't
it's more of a terminology this is a
huge threat and it's gotten
significantly worse with the open border
creation so they're brought in by the
cartels to whom these migrants pay
thousands of thousands of dollars arrive
at the border deeply indebted to those
cartels and then they're trafficked
throughout the country are they not they
are and I really who's doing that
trafficking again that's still cartel
and that's still gang affiliations we
not also have a lot of non-governmental
organizations that are assisting uh in
this in distributing these these
migrants across the country
so so yes so currently they're getting
millions of dollars the non-governmental
organizations are getting millions of
dollars through FEMA but the people get
to choose where they go so it's not
necessarily those non-governmental
organizations that are telling them you
know go to New York and hook up with
this Smuggler right they're just getting
the free plane ticket the free care and
the feeding place to rest for free
nothing's free who's paying for those
plane tickets you are it's going through
FEMA and it's basically money being
laundered and given to the ngos to
support this entire Enterprise the the
Dems tell us this is just a hemispheric
problem beyond our control but when we
had the remaining Mexico policy and
we're completing the border wall and
we're enforcing court order deportations
uh it didn't illegal immigration slow to
a trickle dramatically I agree with the
colleague to my right when people knew
what the parameters were and they knew
they couldn't defraud the system and get
released into the United States before
judge adjudicated their case they
stopped coming that reduced flow allowed
at agents to be more effective Ms Nobles
can you tell us what you thought when
you found out that the suspect in
Kayla's murder was found to be an MS-13
gang member and that it was confirmed by
a simple phone call by the local police
department to El Salvadorian authorities
and then discovered that Federal
authorities never bothered to make that
call before releasing him into the
country
I was um very angry
about the whole thing and what would you
have to say to the organizations and
officials responsible for the illegal
entry literally of millions into this
country over the past couple of years
it's unbelievable like I'm really upset
about how
it was failed at the border
and then allowed him to go with his aunt
and then all you know it's it started
right at the border and then it just
went downhill from there thank you a
chair now recognizes Mr Hunt I remember
Mr Jordan uh I I think the chairman uh
it seems to me Chief Scott that the
fundamental question that that people
are asking is why
why is this happening now at this scale
it's it's certainly the question Miss
Nobles has about what happened to her
daughter Kayla it's a question the
supervisor it's the question the
American people have why is this
happening at this scale is it because
well let me let me you take it give me
an answer Chief what what you think the
why is the short answer is Catch and
Release as long as people know they're
going to be released into the United
States that is the prize they don't care
about all the rest of the immigration
process and until you change that
fundamental incentive that now exists
you will not correct the problem correct
and this Administration decided on day
one I think this is so important for
everyone to fully understand on day one
they decided they were going to stop
building the walls you just talked about
in your question in response to the
chairman they said we'll stop building
the wall we're going to in remain in
Mexico and we're going to release you
once you get here they made that
decision on day one that and that says
it all so people come they say you know
what we won't have to wait in Mexico
there's not going to be wall to get over
and when we get in we're going to get
released to where we want to go who
wouldn't come to the greatest country
ever
good people and a lot of bad people
right and as a result do you think
it seems to me this Administration made
an intentional decision to put in place
policies that have led to everything
we've been talking about this morning do
you agree Chief I agree with that all
the conversations I was part of focused
on Expediting the the release of people
into the United States they were
adamantly opposed to detention and when
you bring in as the chairman just talked
about two million who were who come here
are encountered who were released
another 1.5 million that we know came
but we didn't actually get it they snuck
in somehow they got in somehow three and
a half million people they're going to
be some bad people in there
statistically that is guaranteed drug
dealers
gang members as Miss Nobles knows about
all too well unfortunately they're going
to be there and and also
terrorists
what's the number up to now like we're
close to like a hundred people who've
been on the terrorist watch list who
have encountered on our border because
of an intentional decision the Biden
Administration made on January 20th
2021. is that accurate Chief I believe
that is accurate what what's the
solution
the solution is to put back in place
procedures that make sure that somebody
has due process but they don't get the
prize until a judge adjudicates the case
you have to end Catch and Release and
you can do that through detention or you
can do that through something like the
remainder Mexico program we want to let
good people come to this country
legitimate Asylum Seekers we wouldn't
let them in but you know what our
legislation did it did what you just
described it said when you come to this
country you will either have to wait in
Mexico or we will detain you while we
evaluate your claim and the Democrats
say that's radical that is common sense
and if we'd have kept that policy Kayla
maybe may have been
maybe alive today because but because we
didn't all kinds of bad things happen
that is what has to happen until the
country understands that the Democrats
understand that it is just so basic you
can't just let people come in you have
to evaluate their claim and while you're
doing it they have to be detained or
they have to remain in some other
country before we let them come to the
United States that's the answer
that is the answer and it worked worked
before it'll work again we just have to
have the will to put it back in place so
that the bad things we see happening all
over the country won't continue
correct that'll yield back Mr chairman
chair recognizes Mr Honda
uh first of all I want to thank the
witnesses for being here today to
discuss this very important topic that's
facing our nation uh to you man miss
Nobles I am so sorry for your loss we
failed you
I'm so sorry that we that you lost your
daughter and I can assure you that
you're sitting under day of me that she
lives through you and we will do
everything in our power to make sure
that her voice will be heard for the
future to stop this foolishness from
happening again thank you for being here
ma'am I really appreciate it thank you
wondering what this photo is behind me
this is a photo of a room
and a plush New York City tent made
specifically for migrants
there's Xboxes and flat screens
everywhere and every creature comfort
that you could think of is in this tent
this tit is actually nicer than my room
at West Point I wish I had this stuff
my colleagues on the left often talk
about the long arduous journey to get to
this country and I ask you this why
would illegal immigrants not make their
journey to this country if this was
going to be the end result
in this facility they get free room and
board flat screams three meals a day
free internet and phones
this is the carrot that is bringing
millions of illegal aliens to this
country at a time when this country can
least afford it
for the Democrats migrants jumped to the
top of the list while Americans are
consistently left behind
mayor Eric Adams never thought the
Border crisis would make it to New York
City and now even he has to admit that
the Biden open border policies have
created a quote real life humanitarian
crisis I say again a real life
humanitarian crisis welcome to the party
sir
let me show you a real life humanitarian
crisis and it's America's cities due to
Democrat policies and America cities
have been crumbling long before
President Biden opened the Border
and now that every town that we know of
including New York City is a Border Town
it's about to get worse
this is Philadelphia
these are not illegal immigrants
these are American cities currently
living in abject poverty in this
situation is about to get worse
greetings from Gary Indiana
or is that eastern Ukraine
it's hard to say but I can guarantee you
that if it's for Eastern Ukraine the
government would be printing as much
money as possible to help them but not
our own American citizens
not so good for the people of Gary
Indiana and this is not the dust bowl or
the Great Depression
this is yesterday
in our situation is about to get worse
it's been three months as a trained
derailment in East Palestine and the
people of East Palestine don't have the
necessary resources to rebuild and the
community can't even drink clean water
today and like Philadelphia Gary Indiana
East Palestine Ohio it was a part of the
Forgotten America the Americans Left
Behind as Democrats provide the American
dream to illegal aliens and not to our
fellow Americans
I've got news for you
it's going to continue to get worse
we have San Mateo California
California's 15th congressional district
if some of my colleagues would spend
more time in their districts instead of
inside the Beltway they would see the
destruction that their policies are
causing their own districts and their
own towns and perhaps then they'd have a
different position on the southern
border and it's about to get worse
but wait there's more
this is Redwood City California or is it
Tent City California
does this look like a country that's
thriving does this look like a country
that's equipped to handle a massive
influx of millions more into this
country illegally
I think not
the situation is only going to get worse
this is the death of the American dream
and it starts with the carrot as I
discussed in the very beginning and ends
in abject poverty and despair for
Americans it ended as losing control of
our Sovereign border it ends with
cartels running our Sovereign border and
killing our young people it ends in
fentanyl overdoses it ends in crime
I'm a military guy by trade I've never
seen a directive Duty like this in my
entire life this is insanity
and while we owe the American people an
apology we also owe them to do our damn
jobs
thank you so much for being here and
with that I yield back thank you ma'am
God bless you
gentlemen he goes back your chair
recognizes Mr swole California
thank you chair uh
proud to represent the 14th
congressional district of California
I'll tell the
colleague of mine who represents the
15th that he should probably come and
defend his great District because our
two districts are some of the most
diverse
wealthiest most educated places in
America and one of the biggest
complaints I have from my constituents
is it's too damn expensive to live there
because there's too much Demand on
housing and so we've got a housing
crisis we've got a congestion crisis
because of traffic it doesn't look like
a place that nobody wants to live but
certainly with Open Hearts and open
minds we're doing everything we can to
address immigration
in our country
what I hear from my colleagues in this
hearing is
more chaos and appetite not for
Solutions but an appetite to Pander to
grievances they don't want to solve the
problem that's not worth anything to
them politically they want to stoke fear
when the border patrol seizes fentanyl
at the border God bless them thank them
for doing that they don't celebrate the
border patrol they try and use that to
own the libs and clap back at Joe Biden
where I come from when cops do their job
and catch the bad guys and take drugs
off the street we thank them we don't
use them as political tools because we
don't have any ideas or Solutions when
it comes to immigration when they say we
are a country of open borders that
doesn't recognize the thousands of
border patrol agents who work on the
border work hard every day and are
trying to make sure we can secure the
Border but what it does is it invites
people to believe that the borders are
open and it invites more
immigration to our country again they
don't want to solve this problem if they
wanted to solve this problem they would
have brought to the floor the
comprehensive immigration bill from 2014
where 68 Republican and Democratic
senators voted to secure the border to
put 20 plus thousand more border agents
On the Border to have a pathway for
earned citizenship to take care of the
dreamers who came here by no fault of
their own Republicans and Democrats
voted for that
they walked away from it and so this is
really just more
border theater not border Solutions Mr
Hadfield thank you for being a serious
participant in this process and I would
just like to ask you if we had passed
that comprehensive immigration Bill the
bipartisan Bill back in 2014 where the
most conservative members of the Senate
joined some of the most liberal members
of the Senate
where would we be today as far as
immigration in America
there's no Panacea but we would be in a
much much better place we would have a
fighting chance to address this issue I
mean Congress has not passed immigration
reform about legal Pathways since 1990.
we barely had the inter we didn't have
the internet then right most people
didn't have computers then this was a
totally different world and that illegal
Pathways have been totally ignored for
33 years
and talk to me about uh you know a
shortage of Labor and I see this in all
sectors across my district I see it in
child care I see it in tourism I see it
in Hospitality I see it uh in
construction I've got 50 plus wineries
in my district I see it with the
wineries when Harvest comes what would
an earned pathway or a skilled Workforce
pathway mean for addressing labor
shortages that only lead to every one of
my constituents having to pay more for
the goods and services they consume yeah
that's that's exactly right like we need
legal Pathways so that people can take
jobs that American citizens are not
willing to take and there has been no
movement in that area in in decades and
that people are not coming here to bring
Fentanyl and to kill people they're
coming here
primarily to work and to seek protection
and we need a system that actually
identifies the people that are coming
here for legitimate purposes and to give
them legal Pathways to do that and to
identify the Bad actors but we don't
have that right now our system is
totally out of control because we have
not resourced we have not resourced it
thank you yield back
gentleman yields back if there's no
further business to come before the
subcommittee that will conclude our
hearing I'd like to thank our Witnesses
again for appearing before the committee
today without objection all members will
have five legislative days to submit
additional written questions for the
witnesses or additional materials for
the record and without objection the
hearing is adjourned
foreign